and we can report that a deal
has been done that in now uh
this through uh now uh from a source
uh to sky news uh saying that everything
that the british public was promised
during the 2016 referendum and
in the general election last year is
delivered by this deal this of course
the line from number 10.
we've taken back control of our money
borders laws
trade and our fishing waters this deal
is fantastic news
for families and businesses in every
part of the uk
we've signed the first free trade deal
agreement based on
zero tariffs and zero quotas that has
ever been achieved with the eu the
source going on to say that the deal is
the biggest bilateral trade deal signed
by either side
covering trade worth 668 billion pounds
in 2019. so
a deal has been done we're expecting
those press conferences
very shortly and of course when we get
the full details
of the trade agreement there will be an
incredible amount of
pouring over the detail to see whether
or not
what this number 10 source is saying
is correct fantastic news according to
the number 10 source but of course the
uh inquisition will begin
very shortly including of course from
our deputy political editor sam
coates sam pretty historic moment
absolutely after 1 645 days
uh when britain voted to leave on 23rd
of june 2016
we now are about to find out what the
relationship between the
uk and the eu looks like
finally and boris johnson will announce
uh that at three o'clock
um he will be at payne's to stress that
the deal that he has done
observes all of his red lines and the uk
source that you were
uh quoting foreshadows what the prime
minister is all but certain
uh to say at three o'clock that there
will be
a deal that means that uh we take back
control of our borders in other words we
will end the free system of free
movement
with the european union when it comes to
immigration and that there will be a
system
uh based on zero tariffs and zero
quarters in other words
uh we won't have to pay when goods are
traded with the eu and when we import
goods with the from the eu
and that there won't be any quotas
attached to the goods that come in and
out of the country from our largest
trading partner
block this will be heralded as a big
success by the government
it will probably be heralded as a big
success by the european union but as you
were saying sophie
this is an immensely complicated
document probably around 2
000 pages that will determine the extent
of our and the limits and the working
arrangements
for businesses up and down the country
as well as covering a range of other
other issues including how we do our
security cooperation
with the european union now that we're
no longer a member
of the block